ó meu nome é maria francisca almeida e
gana
tudo coisa pelos presos gostem muito
redondo oferta para ir ao dragão para
quem não é cá e tem detalhes
estou aqui porque tal como vocês agora
rima
estou aqui porque tem um sonho por
captar todos os meus sites
acredito que eu tenho vindo a fazer ao
longo da minha vida
faz-me não grande exemplo mas talvez um
pequeno exemplo para as pessoas que tal
como eu com 16 anos concertante tem
estudos que pensam que nunca vão
concretizar um face lift muito com a
minha mãe e minha irmã carolina de 12
doze anos foi incondicional uma escrita
de violeta que não vai pra ouvir irmã
mexi provisório de haiti e com a minha
mãe que é sem dúvida é a minha grande
inspiração ea mulher quer ser um dia
este é o meu clube e shoppings que eu
gosto de chamar só que os meus amigos
que aturam tudo e mais alguma coisa e
agora falcão tem 17 anos porque sei que
muitas público tem a minha idade é tão
bom temos ninguém podemos confiar e é
tão bom termos pessoas que não só assim
conosco mas também choram e esses
limites sem dúvida um desses exemplos
uma das coisas que também me faz muito
feliz
é com esta teia realidade a ter
concretizado um dos meus grandes sonhos
que escrever um livro que não irei fazer
publicidade mas qualquer pessoa primeiro
título é e e só foi possível pelo apoio
da minha família e pelo fato de eu ter
tido hoje na minha vida que me disseram
que pode ter 14 anos mais do que
escrever não escreva em junho dentro
quiser evitar e nós vamos estar lá para
apoiar e ea verdade é que eu pensava que
não era possível e deus mas em maio do
ano passado evitei meu primeiro livro e
foi promotor de 300 pessoas que irão
abrir no estado diante
gosto do que eu faço com que as pessoas
consigam perceber ou seja gosta de
teatro gosto música gosta de dança e nós
pessoalmente estou a começar a imprimir
e escrever possam ser feliz
tente não vitimizar e nunca desisti de
emoções
pior é quando o mixto mas há pessoas que
estão muito piores que eu me sinta
melhor mas faz com que eu penso miura a
corda está mesmo muito pior que tudo
medo sorriso hit própria
nós vamos começar a pensar em nós
próprios nunca vamos conseguir superar e
tenho um lema que é se eu consigo que
vocês conseguem havia muita gente que
dizia varias várias vezes economia as
escolas num livro é bom é bom e eu por
ele pensava fogo nesse nada especial mas
eu falei tem vindo a acreditar em mim e
sei que não sou perfeita é isso aí
caindo e quando o meu livro já vem de
uma coisa que eu mudança e já vem de
outra ea verdade é que eu acho que a
magia do riso emergido sorriso e nós
conseguimos conhecer cada vez melhor e
com seus outros estar aqui por uma
missão eu hoje vim cá apesar de ter
alguma vergonha e tv que é um público
muito exigente e vim cá e peças correr
mal
no final reúne numa piada e para o norte
na loja isto não esquecer é claro que
está muito sério aqui você chão e ainda
não consegui ver obrigado a vencer a
miami e max são sempre vir à minha vida
é o meu pai também tem um lugar muito
especial no meu coração tal como todos
os nossos pais na maioria dos casos
e apesar do meu pai não estar presente
fisicamente porque faleceu em abril
deste ano é ajudar e eu sei que meu pai
está aqui estivesse cá porque não estava
nessa primeira fila é ver se algo do
passado na alma que ainda nós achamos
tutti frutti peço desculpa da educação
que nossos pais nos deram ea verdade é
que eu não podia ter feito mais e melhor
e não podia ter pai melhore que na caixa
do continente se virava enquanto a
senhora passava as compras e dizia olha
este metal melódico de um livro não está
à venda não conseguimos ainda era fraca
e eu ficava vermelho em cima e meu pai
continuava e eu ia dar uma palestra
meu pai é sempre cômica dia que era por
causa eu filmar mas não era na
perfumaria eu fumava não era o caso ia
cunhas lá atrás assim o pv que os
rapazes se mais fofinhos escolas vez em
nove anos
ainda assim o clube na cabeça alguém
vida é uma coisa assim
- própria é é a área que prefiro um pai
quando 70 anos de poder um pai com 17
por um pai cuidado que seja hora em que
nos é próximo a uma dor que não tem
comparação e que está aqui infelizmente
ainda tem todas as pessoas que ama
consigo não imagina ainda vai o que é
verdade é que por mais que custe e por
mais que neste momento talvez minha vez
que a história será um carinho
não irei fazer porque uma coisa que me
muitas vezes lembra quando estou mais
triste é que o pai não gostava nada
diverte
o papa estava por vir e eu disse antes
eu achava que encarava a vida de uma
forma mais ou menos positiva dentro das
limitações da deficiência que acham que
temos é que ela tenha se primeiramente
dar um carrinho é verdade é que agora eu
acredito que estou a seguir o rumo certo
da minha vida que vou fazer aquilo que
orgulhará o meu pai que é isso que todos
os dias penso em tomar uma decisão pensa
o que é que vai fazer mais feliz
o que o meu pai queria que eu fizesse e
é esse caminho que eu tenha que importar
a maioria das vezes aliás tem que fazê
lo sem todas as mensagens da teimosia ea
docência pra ele porque e porque ao
longo da nossa vida vamos acontecendo
coisas boas coisas mas já me aconteceu e
dar uma palestra uma escola eo pessoal
vantagem todos ppt provação e vai ter
nem de outras formas assim dói e também
já não consigo ter uma palestra de uma
hora numa escola em piche e ninguém
bater palmas e eu é que eu vou e os
miúdos estavam assim vai tentar não sul
ao contrário do caso estes possam pensar
como eu vim aqui outros setores não
vieram
não sou melhor que ninguém não me acho
melhor que ninguém se uma pessoa foi ter
sucesso mas uma pessoa ainda mais 80 de
fracassos
a verdade é que se eu fosse contabilizar
os nãos que já se via ao longo da minha
vida que já não se referiam ao shin
mas a diferença para um volume entre
entre eu eo diogo por exemplo tem mirar
e também está terá muito sucesso e que
outros mostraram mais eh eh eh eh eh
verdade é que por mais difícil que
aqueles cuja experiência nós temos que
lutar por elas e temos que acreditar que
o sonho comanda a vida já dizia fernando
pessoa é e eu queria também necessária
que explicita porque não estava me
alongar muito é que mais e mais acção
com expressão as coisas que vocês querem
concretizar
nunca devem esquecer delas porque eu já
estou estou em casa e e olho para minha
família e pense furto em um filme é tão
boa
estudou num colégio que adoro tem
professores que todos disputam por mim
por pior que esteja ao país eu estou
otimista apesar de um dia que está ali
está processando janeiro é crítica em
portugal que eu tenho meu futuro
clique em portugal quer viver e quer
constituir família e as pessoas me it's
you ever é que quando olha a minha volta
e vejo muito fantástico em que isto
penso pra que chorar porque não me
refiro porque eu ainda tenho muito muito
estranho ver programa virtual como todos
nós temos que nos preocupar e seguirem
este foi um dia fantástico como
organizam fantástico querer subir já
agradeci o convite fica muito gosto e eu
queria deixar aqui presente é que eu
tenho 70 anos
estou a concretizar um sonho estou a
lutar todos os dias para ter medo de
entrar na universidade é uma coisa que
vocês também é vocês só que ele não vai
virar várias coisas e também devem ter e
também devem ter atenção por mais que a
defesa precisa ir à noite que na área
podemos do auditor pois poderia sair
acho que o importante é que o mais
importante tem a minha vida para além da
minha família são os valores que este
mico tio eo conquistou o carinho
transição determinada que tem muita
história aqui
acho que assim não não ultrapassar o
tempo é que eu queria dizer mais uma vez
é que o tempo os votos sanções não se
utilizem considerem suas felizes por
levar nós somos por mais problemas 500
nossa vida há sempre é o segundo de que
o dia entre os crimes genuinamente
revelada que se chama aconteceram coisas
bizarras
neste pequeno mundo que eu entrar que o
mundo é pequeno eo everton é parte
pequena mas chega um grande boom da
literatura
se aconteceram coisas bizarras e como
animar um carinho comigo uma escola e
osório flores era uma briga
constantemente gritar franklin stein
continuar foi à frente do time e eu
desculpo apesar do problema e ela não
evita a gritar não sair até se fred está
em franca está em franca design e 80
falar
já o tema já aconteceram coisas
fantásticas como uma rapariga vir falar
comigo final e dizer eu nunca tive
coragem para dizer que estava a escrever
porque naquela fase do 8º ano é mais
fischer boel duque ter um sonho e que
concretizá lo e evitar equipas de topo
letra eu ganhei inspiração tubos trás no
que é possível e agora eu vou acreditar
no meu sonho
voltar pra mim própria muito obrigado
pela presença e até a próxima